Please welcome Björn Ulvaeus!
-Welcome.
-Thank you.
Was that an actual rumour?
I don't even remember that.
But it probably was.
Because a lot of people went,
"what a gimmick, two married couples."
A redhead and a blonde beauty
who could sing, to boot.
It was too good to be true.
Björn, you're throwing a party,
aren't you?
-You're a bit of a party planner.
-Yes, I suppose.
We saw some clips fromMamma Mia!,
which was a huge hit.
Now there's a sequel,
Mamma Mia! The Party.
What is "the party"?
It came out of...
At the end of the stage musical,
people stand up, sing and dance,
and there's sort of a party vibe.
People sort of wanted
to keep that party going afterwards.
That's the idea behind
Mamma Mia! The Party.
We take this atmosphere to
a restaurant setting, a Greek taverna.
It's Nikos, the owner of the taverna,
and his friends and family.
Between them,
a story takes place each night.
But the songs are different
to those inMamma Mia!
So, when it comes to looking after
the ABBA legacy, so to speak,
you seem to be the most active
in that sense.
It's mostly your responsibility,
like a big brother.
It's probably a bit of a coincidence.
I think it all began withMamma Mia!
I really liked the idea of it.
I saw the musicalGrease
with my children,
and I had a vision of what it could be.
Happy, cheerful fun for the whole family
with lots of hit songs.
I thought, well,
I really need to do this,
because I'm actually able
to make this happen.
It was kind of an experiment
that I started.
I was ready to abort it
if it wasn't panning out.
Because the most important thing
was always the songs, and ABBA,
that this wouldn't hurt them
in any way.
Do you have to ask their permission
for every little thing you do?
-You bet. I sure have to.
-Are they difficult...?
Not for everything,
but for major things like this.
-Are they difficult?
-Not at all.
A couple of them had their doubts
aboutMamma Mia!
but for this,
they all gave their go-ahead.
The other three came
to theMamma Mia!premiere.
-Will they come this time?
-If they'll come? They've been invited.
And I guess we'll see...if they turn up.
-It looks like you know they will come.
-Really?
That's your interpretation.
When you send out your invites
you ask for a reply, don't you?
They need to reply, don't they?
-Reply to...?
-You know, RSVP.
Right, they've all RSVPed.
Yes. I can tell you that much.
And are they nice RSVPs?
They all write very nice
and clear RSVPs, yes.
You've also been actively involved
with the ABBA museum.
Are you a bit of a control freak
in that sense?
No, I just wanted a museum
dedicated to me.
No, I...
No, it just suddenly dawned on me
that a museum in Stockholm
was going to happen.
I wanted to make sure the quality of it
would be the best I could make it,
and that's why I became involved,
not because I wanted to.
But once I did, it was rather fun.
Because that young man
with the peculiar suits,
he sort of became
this other person to me.
A kind of "historical figure"
I could tell a story about.
And that made things easier.
You've said that you and Benny...
...have got one more musical in you.
I've said I think we do,
that we might have another one in us.
Are you working on one?
We've been...
I'm being very evasive again.
We've got a few ideas in circulation.
Right. Are they any good?
If they're in circulation,
they're good ideas, I'll say that much.
But nothing's been decided yet.
What's the process like? You've made
a few of these musicals by now.
-First you have to find a story?
-Yes. That's the main thing.
And where do you find them,
in literature?
In literature, in drama, in films...
Or you could start from scratch,
like we did withChess.
It doesn't matter where it comes from,
it's wherever you get the best idea.
When you say that you may have
one musical left in you,
it's a bit sad, because it's something
you say at a certain age, isn't it?
Yes...
And you're someone
who thinks a great deal about death.
I used to think more about death
five years ago than I do now.
How so?
Well, I was 65 years old at the time.
And it's not unusual
to worry about death.
You're too young to understand
what I'm talking about.
But as the horizon closes in on you,
you start thinking about it more.
I think all people do.
But...I believe it helps
to reflect on it a lot.
It allows you to face the fact
that it is all coming to an end.
Then you learn to live with it
and you think about it less.
You're an outspoken atheist,
so the end, that's really it to you.
Yes.
You've been very actively talking
about wanting to die on your own terms.
Euthanasia, to put it bluntly,
should be an option in your opinion.
-Yes.
-What are your thoughts on that?
Well, I've personally witnessed...
...the final years of both my parents
and my parents-in-law.
And they were difficult years.
And I thought,
I definitely don't want to go that way.
So I began thinking about euthanasia.
And I think, in a country like Sweden,
politicians ought to properly
look into how it could work.
But they're not even willing to do
that much. They won't touch the issue.
They're so afraid of it, even though
I've read that a majority of Swedes
would be favourable
to some kind of euthanasia.
You say the final years are difficult.
But isn't that just part of life?
Yes, but it feels so pointless,
seeing your close ones suffer
in the manner I've seen them do.
It feels so utterly pointless.
I think it would be comforting
for elderly people to know
that you won't have to go that way.
That you could be in charge of how
and when you wanted to end it.
People who oppose that sort of thinking
tend to point out
that elderly people often don't want
to be a burden on their families.
That they might feel pressure
to accept a solution like that.
Yes, it's hard to determine...
It's a complex and really tough issue.
But it does work in many countries,
and has done for many years.
Belgium, Netherlands, Switzerland...
Not to mention the state of Oregon
in the United States.
They've had euthanasia for 17 years.
And a rather uncontroversial
version of it, in my view.
I think you need
two independent medical opinions
saying you've got a chronic condition
and less than six months to live.
Then they'll prescribe something
that lets you end it whenever you wish.
As a civilised, secular country,
we ought to be able to implement that.
On tonight's show, amongst other topics,
we're going to discuss perhaps
the biggest issue in Europe today,
the situation for refugees
and the immigration issue.
I know you've actively sought out
an immigrant friend.
-Yes, that's right.
-You didn't know anyone before?
No. We had partnered up
with the Red Cross
during the Gothenburg Opera revival
ofKristina from Duvemåla.
We figured
an epic emigrant story like that
could have a positive effect
on the whole debate.
Then I learned the Red Cross promoted
something calledKompis Sverige.
It's for people like me,
because we live in a segregated society.
And I realised I never get to meet
any of the new arrivals.
I never get to hear what it's like
to come to Sweden that way.
So I got in touch withKompis Sverige.
They interviewed me to find out
about my interests and who I am.
-And likewise with...
-I assume they knew who you were?
Who youreallyare.
It went a bit deeper than that.
And they did likewise with new arrivals
and paired us up.
And they paired me up with Issam,
who is Palestinian.
He's been in Sweden for a few years.
-He and I meet up...
-Is he your age, or younger...?
He's in his sixties.
We've met for lunch a couple of times
and have started to talk.
I'll get him to speak more
in Swedish eventually.
For now, it's mostly in English.
We're meeting again in a few weeks.
-What do you talk about?
-Everything.
Politics, religions, tradition, culture,
things I really want to know about.
And I get a first-hand account
from someone who is from there.
It must be peculiar for Issam, who was
meant to get a "typical Swedish buddy".
-Exactly.
-Then it turns to be Björn from ABBA.
Was the choice between you
and Ingvar Kamprad?
I don't know
who the other candidates were.
But he was a bit surprised.
He didn't know who I was
when we first met.
-So that was a...
-He didn't know?
Oh, so when he met you
he realised it was you.
-In the interviews, he had no idea.
-Right, it was a blind date.
It was a typical blind date.
It's really dating, what we're doing.
But it's a great, simple, tangible way
for everyone to engage.
Anyone of us can make
a newly arrived friend
and learn what it's like to come
to Sweden as an immigrant.
Great to hear, great to have you here.
We'll have some more guests.
Mamma Mia! The Partypremieres
in Stockholm later in January.
-Thank you, Björn Ulvaeus.
-Thank you.